cigarettes could be a game-changer in
public health helping millions of people
to quit smoking something in the region
of seven million people a year are dying
because they smoke these cigarettes can
provide a route out of smoking for many
of those people more than forty million
people worldwide are vaping but a decade
after they first came onto the market
new cigarettes and more controversial
than ever before there was yet another
death connected to the use of
e-cigarettes nicotine exposure during
adolescents can uniquely harm the
developing adolescent brain thirty
countries have banned e-cigarettes
outright but the facts have gone up in
smoke
[Music]
the death toll linked to vaping is
climbing tonight infected lungs nearly
collapsed Colorado's first case of a
rare vaping related illness America has
been in the grip of a health scare over
a cigarette because of a deadly outbreak
of what is being called a volley a
volley is an electronic cigarette or
vaping product to use associated lung
injury people were complaining over
spiritual symptoms really having trouble
breathing and in some cases it was fatal
since April 20 1960 deaths and over two
and a half thousand hospital cases have
been reported in America the American
Medical Association and the Centers for
Disease Control advised the country's 11
million vapors to quit
seven states propose partial or total
bans some politicians called for a
national ban on all cigarettes yet the
health scare isn't down to nicotine
based vaping but illicit cannabis vaping
products tetrahydrocannabinol THC is the
ingredient in cannabis that makes you
high as though people have been vaping
THC for a long time but at some point
vitamin E acetate was cut in with THC
and that became a contaminant that
people were inhaling vitamin E acetate
thickens the THC and makes it seem like
it's more high quality than it actually
is there are over 40 million vapors
across the world but this outbreak of
ivali is unique to America in the United
States you've got a market that is
really not well regulated it's possible
for manufacturers to put in these
dangerous chemicals into the liquids but
in addition to that you've got this
varied legalization of cannabis and
heavy usage of cannabis oil put the two
together and you've got a very dangerous
situation the misconception that this
ivali outbreak is caused by vaping
nicotine products could have dire
consequences
globally more than 8 million people die
every year from smoking tobacco but also
inhaling secondhand smoke almost half a
million of these in America alone come
to where the flavor is the concern is
the e-cigarette users who have used an
e-cigarette to stop smoking will go back
to smoking
if that happens many lives will be lost
[Music]
there's there's a fair chance I'd be
dead right now if it wasn't for
electronic cigarettes I started smoking
when I was nine I smoked for 41 years
the last 30 of those trying to quit I
poked my head in the door here at 9:06
vapor and 20 minutes later I walked out
a nonsmoker then marks list went one
step further he decided to buy the vape
shop in Michigan they had introduced him
to e-cigarettes my customers come from a
wide variety of backgrounds ages the
average customer is a middle-aged
professional but they do have one thing
in common and that's a desire to quit
smoking yes there is major concern that
vaping is appealing to increasingly
younger customers the device has now
helped countless teenagers in 2018 the
Food and Drug Administration reported an
alarming increase in high school
students vaping a 78% increase in 2018
alone I am officially declaring each
cigarette use among youth an epidemic in
the United States the reaction we're
seeing in the United States is a kind of
mass hysteria the problem is nothing
like what it's being portrayed as by the
public health officials in the United
States the evidence doesn't support that
kind of language
a National Youth tobacco survey in
America revealed that there are many
more teenagers trying cigarettes but the
number using them more regularly nearly
everyday is far smaller and the vast
majority of those previously used
tobacco products what you see is
actually that among never smokers a
cigarette noose is rare the use
regularly on a daily or nearly daily
basis is extremely rare and among all of
those the reports of cravings and signs
of addiction is very small whereas with
a cigarette you see the conversion rate
from trying a cigarette to becoming a
regular addicting smoker is really quite
high in people who just use an
e-cigarette and have never smoked is
really quite low
the e-cigarette phenomenon has really
called into question whether it's just
nicotine on its own that is highly
addictive or whether there's something
else going on this goes against decades
of widely held beliefs around the
addictive nature of nicotine nicotine is
the chemical that causes addiction it
can change the way your brain works
causing you to crave more nicotine
combustible cigarettes are far more
addictive than vaping products because
they deliver many other chemicals along
with nicotine what we call mono a mean
oxidase inhibitors when you use nicotine
that causes release of dopamine that
dopamine is part of the dependence
process now if you've got a monoamine
oxidase inhibitor that you're inhaling
as well and that's preventing that
dopamine from being broken down as
amplifying the effect of nicotine
cigarettes are actually giving you a
cocktail of psychoactive drugs and bingo
you've got a highly addictive product
when if you had nicotine alone not so
much if nicotine is more addictive in
cigarettes than vapes then is it harmful
on its own
we've conflated nicotine with cigarettes
so nicotine was the devil
really it's not nicotine that's causing
the damage in the doses that you get it
from a cigarette the risks are minimal
and the reason we know that is because
there is a part of the world which takes
in a lot of nicotine in a form that
isn't smoking Scandinavians have been
using snus a form of chewing tobacco for
centuries frequent users receive high
concentrations of nicotine on a daily
basis for decades now if nicotine were
causing the kind of consequences that
smokers suffer from we would definitely
say it and we don't see it but the myth
still persists
it's a myth that is driving health
campaigns in America and around the
world especially focusing on teenagers
scientists say it can change your brain
there's a narrative going around now
born out of the United States around to
nicotine being damaging to the
adolescent brain this is based on
studies in animals in their version of
the adolescent stage of development but
the epidemiology itself is not backing
up what they are trying to assert people
have been using nicotine for centuries
if nicotine in adolescents were causing
this lasting damage to the brain would
we not have seen it what critics will
say to this is that absence of evidence
is not evidence of absence and that is a
good point that said you should be
careful about getting too hysterical
about the long-term impacts of children
very clean nicotine
British public health experts say that
e-cigarettes are around 95 percent less
harmful than tobacco that's only a back
of the cigarette packet calculation so
other than nicotine what else is in them
the liquid contains glycerol or
propylene glycol which is the substance
that makes the visible vapor basically
what we use in stage smoke there's a lot
of studies done on it and we know what
effect it has on the lungs as far as we
can tell it doesn't cause an
inflammatory reaction it causes a local
dryness in the membranes also trace
amounts of heavy metals from the heating
elements can be inhaled heavy metals are
not the sort of thing you want to be
inhaling in any amount it's fair to say
that we don't really know the long-term
effects that these are going to have on
anyone who's Apes indeed for any of the
components of e-cigarettes but the point
about vaping is you're supposed to use
it to stop smoking which is really
harmful and then use vaping to help
yourself quit in 2018 the global ISA
Guerette market was valued at fifteen
point seven billion dollars it's
expected to almost triple by 2023
appealing flavours have helped the
vaping industry to flourish I've got a
blue raspberry candy a strawberry Kiwi
custard one of my favorites
whipped peanut butter and caramel it
tastes great and it helps people to quit
smoking yet the many flavours have
caused an uproar in America cherry crush
how can you sit here and say you're not
marketing to children today Michigan
will become the first state in the
nation to ban flavored cigarettes and
vaping products marks Liz gave testimony
to help block an emergency flavor ban in
his state of Michigan
the numbers in my shop are that 99
percent of my customers use flavors the
flavors are absolutely necessary and
they are the key to quitting smoking in
early 2020
president Trump banned almost all
flavors of e-cigarette cartridges across
the nation and globally these cigarettes
are now entirely banned in 30 countries
for many of us that sounds crazy because
in those same countries you've got high
smoking prevalence and they're not
really doing very much about it in
Lebanon for example where each
cigarettes are now banned the World
Health Organization says almost 26% of
all male deaths were tobacco related in
2017 my concern is that forbidding me
cigarettes is going to deter smokers
from switching to something far less
deadly countries should regulate
e-cigarettes very tightly rather than
banning them public health England they
are now currently opening up vape shops
in their hospitals they know it works
they know it saves lives governments
need to think about tightly regulating
e-cigarettes take a leaf out of the book
of the EU what gets into them the
quality of the device is and tightly
control how they're marketed what you
want from a public health perspective is
to capture the benefits of e-cigarettes
as a tool for helping smokers to quit
whilst not appealing to young people who
never would have smoked at all
I'm Sarah I directed this film if you
want to learn more about vaping you can
click on the link opposite which will
take you to some of the economists
coverage and some data and research we
use for making this film don't forget to
Like and subscribe thanks for watching
[Music]